sos retard bonjour quel est votre numéro
client
s'étirant de 25 ans journaux supply
chain sur quel type de retard en effet
réunion 30 minutes environ sur ok c'est
parti je vous conseille de vous dépêcher
un petit peu monsieur oui
bezos allait dépêcher vous on va
commencer
bon on a pas mal de boulot alors on va
commencer par le dossier choco des
livres qui commence fiche on te plaît
j'y joue
bon filon on est prêt c'est là alors
pour le dossier chaud que des versions
été dit on pourrait pas dans madame
s'cusez moi pardon alors on pourrait
miser notre à tj sur le haut ce que vous
pouvez ouvrir les portes s'il vous plaît
on pourrait miser la stratégie surjoue
caucus et 58e
le placement au danemark était tout
petit peu plus fun donc si on consomme 7
op sur notre mascotte choc aucune fiche
on vous allez bien ici qu'à choquant que
qu'il va être au centre d'un peu pop et
on peut vraiment montrer le côté délire
et fun de choco délire donc en gros
voilà tout ça pour dire qu'il faut oui
oui je veux qu'elle revienne là donc je
pense vraiment qu'il faut faire acclamer
par les villes là je ferai mon tout
court terme 1 go to action sur facebook
et twitter ont créé une page pour choco
qu ayant bien alors j'ai trop combien de
fois depuis ce que c'est que ce bordel
fiche on en fait c'est compliqué ses
pieds de veau monsieur là vraiment je me
désole
qu'est ce que c'est que supporter
foot et laissez nous travailler là
on a le temps si on est toujours en
retard tu vois thibault lui il est
toujours une ue thibout en proposant une
interactivité et faire un call to action
à peu près